[Music]
he arrived in America he conquered
Austin he was promptly banned from
Austin and YouTube they tried to stop
him but now he's back yeah at this point
they forced my hand be people you look
like you had a few too many fights in
your Monday June 11th just when you
thought it was safe to go back to the
LGBTQA I'd be number two festivals I
couldn't think you guys suck
I'm going to sleep my pee pee pee fufufu
lahter with crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's June which marks louder with
Crowder's third annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe learning and
appreciating all the great cultures this
world has to offer this week allow us to
be your Sherpa to the talented tough and
fantastic country last week all the
costume contest winners send in your
costumes tweet me at s Crowder and of
course producing me in video studio as
always you can tweet him at not gay
jeered with your photo shops your
comments or your costumes for cultural
appropriation months winner gets
obviously a free t-shirt Ranger panties
and a lock of knock' Jarrett's hair and
I inadvertently fulfilled my obligations
trying conclusions are we good yeah you
call me not you call me Nucky daddy okay
it's for some reason that sounds like a
very gay daddy
we have great guys we have sargon of
akkad we have Dean Cain and with Derek
smalls of spinal tap yes on the show the
basis for spinal tap one of my greatest
accomplishments actually ever really
there but only a few people have really
really really really wanted having a
show you know Alice Cooper is amongst
them yeah and Derek smalls basis of
spinal tap is also hey question of the
day before we move on is what sucks more
today what do you think genuinely that
the state of free speech across our
country or even across the world Europe
and we're going to talk about the Tommy
Robinson situation particularly as it
relates to social media or the World Cup
which sucks more also Julia Whittle hi
Jeremy fired you sommelier which means
he knows a lot about wine at G Morgan Jr
how are you oh jeez I'm just so happy I
can you celebrate with I just brought a
beer because it's got bubbles in that
celebratory that is it I just I could go
home for a metaphore tea it's not quiet
I couldn't they're legal in Missouri
because to me people are getting they
were getting a Pan's Labyrinth in the
face on work sites and then once they
broke the bottle
stabbing people with it so loyal so
loyal could to go 45 and of course fen
computer are you ready with overlays I
just struck Washington DC and the rocket
works better than your mic that's not
working perfectly but yeah maybe I'll
just make it to Hawaii crash into the
ocean but you can track my flat path oh
I'm Twitter thing is making everyone
sneaky Hey so we're gonna be we actually
been official statement from kim
jeong-hoon later
he's been relatively quiet and it's a
little conflicted but we have news of
the day to get to first so Jim Acosta is
an insufferable prick let's lead with
that here he is caught in the hot
microphone justifying shouting questions
at the whole Trump Kim summit listen to
the smugness
all day all day baby
all day all today all day long entitled
s which is ironic though actually
because all night long is actually now
Donald and Kim song just love I just
love how spend computer is unable he's a
little holding a depiction of their
nuclear program looking forward to
seeing looking forward to seeing your
full full sting come to fruition on
Monday I'm looking forward to it a lot
and just are you just forgetting to turn
on your microphone I just know you're a
[ __ ] man I just don't yeah but I
don't want to make too many North Korean
I don't know I won't make too many
noises at this launch you from a carrier
if my life depended on I wouldn't I'm
just gonna fail on the ramp BPI question
what do you do the adoption processes
from North Korea UV Trump's got me luck
I think you just chase around the
Jillian with loopholes I think you just
chasing her with a piece of cheese and
you pretty much get whoever you want
yeah I think they taste you around forth
and kill Dear Leader's speaks directly
into their mind like Charles Xavier
huh no other news of the day the UN is
officially blamed and condemned Israel
for the recent violence in Gaza this
comes to us from Washington Post of
course it approved the Palestinian
backed resolution when on Wednesday
blaming Israel for violence in Gaza and
deploring it's quote excessive use of
force with no mention of the fact that
Hamas who had the destruction of all
Jews was in their charter until very
recently yeah you and also the minute
that the 36 accusers be charged with
quote stealing all of Cosby's pills so
they're in yeah I'm increasingly
convinced that if Hitler were around the
day the left would ensure him a victory
but un un un on the Left I mean come on
yeah the wrong people I feel like if
they went back and looked at the
Holocaust to be like yeah you guys kind
of had it coming yeah
well you know what you don't think that
Hamas would carry out the Holocaust they
could tomorrow
absolutely they're just Holocaust
deniers who beat their wives yeah the
fun fact is that the person in yeah I
just said that like a few weeks ago that
most youth reduce social behavior that
the Holocaust happened PPP so that's the
position that they do to theirs
due to their social behavior of dying
from inhaled toxic fumes can you believe
that those Jews they're there so be on
the brink of palate like here's what
even if you think that Israel as an
occupant put this way in any other
situation if you thought someone was
occupying a land but the land consisted
of people who wanted to wipe out an
entire race with people oh thank god
they're occupied thank god they're no
longer running the show doing that
speaking of running the show Netflix
film crew they're now banned from
staring flirting or hugging under the
new rules I'm so happy
[Laughter]
Whoopi Goldberg strolls on I so sale
Rodman coin I think yet we've coin or
something
so Netflix they've banned film crews
from looking at anyone for over five
seconds other rules include not asking
were pals phone numbers and they're
urging staff feeling pestered to yell
quote stop don't do that again so this
isn't bonds to me to and it's not this
really a bad response but it's it's led
to some changes for Netflix prompted
them to actually halt production on Bill
O'Reilly highly anticipated directorial
debut the biographical Roger Ailes
picture The Chronicles of crotch cam
yeah also the production of the highly
anticipated sequel to a Spacey Jam that
was one fun fact about that one Spacey
was not supposed to be a cameo but he in
his audition he blew everyone he blew
everyone away here's your chance
do your dance at the at the space at the
Space Jam stop I didn't write it also no
longer available is the notorious Bill
Nye saves the world episode dry humping
the craft services table that one almost
seems like it was it almost seems he was
toxifying the world Bill Nye
but he taught you how to make your own
ketchup afterwards I'm not
happy you tell you that that Hani was
b-bar feel like really honey I didn't
know that I guess it's okay thank you
hump the the the the the Quiznos
catering hey Elon Musk's boring company
reportedly just won a bid to build a
high-speed underground rail in Chicago
even muster you know you love the Elon
Musk's there's fun computer so this is
actually quote we're really excited to
work with the mayor and the city to
bring this new high-speed public
transportation system to Chicago the
boring company said hopefully it's
faster than a speeding bullet set up all
of Chicago let's train to go everywhere
yeah I think we never are Detroit would
be calling the Chicago PD a problem no
but it's more powerful than a gun
confiscation I'll take it I take it
that's good I'll go I just submitted
still 15 minutes respond time yes the
Troy 15-minute 5858 response rate is 11
I think Chicago is actually good on them
it's like six I think I just don't
believe it to like yeah there's no one
left to kill in this I got crazy online
too alright a little hyper a little
hyper the US House just approved a ban
on Wednesday by the way on the
importation employ almost like I would
say in poor taste the importation and
trafficking of this is an actual spent
computer there's an actual story rights
nectar so yeah okay I want to make sure
because people say you're just making
these up to four like the Anne Frank it
was a real story traffic an anatomically
correct child sex dolls and robots that
quote normalized sex between adult and
minors the proposal was approved in the
house and now it moves on to the Senate
but if you make child sex robots see
illegal people will be forced to build
their own sex dolls and back alleys
argued NAMBLA dan only the child sex
robots will have them oh the first
models by the way we're nicknamed r2d2
year-old and c3 this many had a rough
get in the vent you might have been the
best the senator who votes no on this I
know there will be one I'm convinced oh
in a decade from now they'd just be
considered forward-thinking ahead of
their time yes salons are you on board
senator Sanders you're running for
president but says here that you voted
no on ban
anatomically correct child sex robots
have all of them issue we have okay so
we do update to a story here we had this
guy's manager on not long ago
and if you've been following the news
this is not to get sued but it is pretty
sure so let's just set this up Kay
Marley was dead to begin with the UK no
longer has free speech well talked with
star Ghana but it doesn't exist you've
heard us say it time and time again plea
there's no I don't even think anyone is
trying to argue anymore they're trying
to argue to what degree they limit
speech I'm saying okay we're going
forward in a kind of authoritarian so
before we get to tell me Robinson what
we and the hell if I'd go to the UK no
those fools are crazy I can't speak even
though I can't speak I can imagine well
so you don't chip things so people like
like Lauren Southern that's not how they
work and Britney had they've been banned
from entering the country count dank
EULA of course you remember fine for
making the pub to a Nazi salute which
sounds worse than it actually is when
you see the video meanwhile though
flying the ISIS flag in London you're
aces yeah apparently that's not a
problem
and obviously Tommy Robinson is still in
prison we talked about this we had timed
Robinson's manager on I thought was it
two weeks ago now two weeks ago yeah and
the concern is now and he talked about
this he's been moved to a new prison
that's allegedly significantly more
dangerous with a higher Muslim
population now there's been some
confusion over the exact details right
so I don't want to spread any
misinformation here's the most recent
update from his manager Kalin Robertson
himself there was some confusion
circulating on Twitter there may be some
people try to say was seventy percent
Muslim the prison yeah some huge number
yeah and it turns out that that is not
correct at all and they may have just
flipped it and got in a mistake but then
there were a lot of other sites that ran
with it who didn't factor and this is
what I want to make this clear before we
get to Tom I want this is why I
absolutely despise the conspiratorial
right it's it's true the fake news
exists not just exclusively on the left
okay and it makes it much harder for us
to do our job
or for you to go out there and be
properly armed with information when
people are more interestin clicks and
they aren't telling the truth inflating
the number to an increased number of
Muslims that is not the accurate number
which had to be I believe it was I
believe they took it back if I'm not
mistaken I believe they retracted it
yeah I think they put it down what it
like yeah they moved into a prison with
a higher Muslim population where it's
more dangerous that's enough yeah when
we get to what's happened on YouTube and
social media tenders it's enough the
truth is enough the truth is always
enough Inessa double-edged sort of of
the new age of digital media is that
right comes with the extra set of
responsibilities once once my time I
think I feel like even riots were a
little more genuine because people were
on board with it's more of a singular
yeah narrative of news
now you can anybody can from any blog or
from anywhere in the world can throw
their own spin on things and be taken as
legitimate so yeah you gotta be vigilant
no matter which sites you're on no
matter where here's the thing you know
what's crazy we just we just had kim
jeong-hoon in donald trump singing all
night long okay this is not the epitome
of journalism and we do the work and
some and we've come out in issued
retractions we've gotten some things
wrong when new news has come in these
people who are out there trying to
convince you that they are real news by
the way don't watch this is your only
news source we're a late-night show okay
but we are meticulous in trying to be
correct so it's not by accident that a
news organization or a right-wing blog
that employs three four five times as
many people as on this show gets it
wrong that's by design yeah spend
computer yeah I mean it really just
hurts your cost BP because now the
left-wing media and leftist they can
just point at this and go like look
they're lying rights trying to inflate
this and that makes people like us look
bad too because they were gonna be
associated with those people as well
look at her I do with the alt right it's
like all rights like Ben Shapiro was a
notorious Jewish net shut up it's just
really done yeah they're handing out
tiki torches that they are and so you
can binge yeah exactly and that being
said there is something here something
we do know okay and it's just it's just
concerning a video that time Darwin made
it was titled I won't be around for much
longer was taken down from YouTube
because it violated Community Guidelines
so this so the fact that this coincides
is is is bone-chilling ly scary the good
news is a lot of people did their due
diligence and took the clip downloaded
the clip before was taken down so we
have a montage of some of it here they
want to remove me to silence me to
discredit me
they have tried to stop me in every
possible way I don't want to take away
the final thing I have my voice
I don't doubt one day they will wipe me
off social media completely forever the
media will be able to tell you whatever
they want about me now I have no way of
responding if they can do it to me they
can do it to you and what do they do
they removed it immediately almost seems
like he was a prophet he is
foreshadowing acts of violence and
censorship committed against him and
he's the one in violation that video
predicting that he would be found in
violations for non violations was
removed as a violation get your head
around that these people it's scared
because at the point where they don't
care that you're watching yeah they're
not trying to hide anymore and that's
what's scary well people aren't really
stepping up and fighting stuff like this
I think or they're trying to but they
don't really have much of a mechanism
what do you do if Twitter bans you get a
half page and learn and build rich yeah
exactly hear his name in the hallways of
Google and themselves and you know what
I'm talking about yeah but how many
people can do that right and so it comes
down to people like you having the
ability to go do that for everybody else
a lot of people can you just have to be
the pig who bigs it build his house out
of straw builds is outside of out of
brick as opposed to the brothers who did
straw and wood wood stick strong wood
sticks but you know must have pissed off
that one see this coming late for right
next to it
take care about the environment it's not
that expensive right down the block just
let you know some of these organizations
that went out with this myth of the 70%
Muslim population but they have far more
money than we do yeah where do they
typically do they often just tend to
[ __ ] what's happening on YouTube listen
we [ __ ] and we try and make it funny
that's why we created mug Club it's what
allows us to be sustainable and we try
and do sketches to draw awareness to it
but we have bill Richman number 10 we
have also his firm on retainer and we
are a thorn in the side of social media
believe you me we've planned for this
and you will know about it if we end up
having to fight to a higher degree than
we are right now so here's the thing the
UK courts and social medias are working
together and not just a silenced Tommy
and to put him in prison but but to
silence any reports of their actions
against him that's what's crazy right
now and this is how the Left operate
some people were yeah I am making the
grocery generalization because this is
this is exclusive to the left they
portray the aggressors as the victims
and they and they have and there's no
one who can call on us they paint Tommy
as the villain and is reporting
as a crime against the poor Muslim rate
gangs the poor the poor migrant rapists
all he did was rape a kid they
technically are a minority so they do
have the immoral and that is true mommy
Robinson might have uh named the jury by
reporting about how this man raped a kid
don't you understand how we don't can't
we find common ground probably not um by
the way here's something you know same
things happened to us before so good
example is very recently why people
don't know this and actually spend
computer you did some research with with
reg the Beast here we found some things
out yes just today right before the show
right before doing this we did a civil
non-violation change my mind video last
week in Austin right
we had a [ __ ] sit down with us there
you go there's a violation for you just
find a reason so antiphon and the like
they actively and repeatedly called to
firebomb us to firebomb us to firebomb
our table you can see these pictures
yeah so I actually posted this to
Instagram saying like hey guys keep an
eye out and it was removed as a
violation we're saying this person wants
to firebomb us so if you that make sure
we don't get firebomb isn't this is a
violation here's the crazy thing
do you remember Charles Hermes a
professor at UT Arlington who's still
there who said it was a Nazi who posted
fake names and he's saying gas the juice
and never took it back this person who
wanted us to be fire bombed in Austin is
a co-chair the Democratic Socialist
works at UT Austin and ran Bernie's
Austin campaign these aren't crazy
fringe extremists they've been arrested
for rape for calling to report rape
right but you said the rape word ID we
have to take you in
you said the are words not our fault but
I didn't do the R word he's still doing
it now sir calm down we are sending the
play for a line to we pose her to
protect our team and the fans we had
fans showing up to change my mind people
were like oh you're here and there's no
way to stop the spread of information we
was the only time we were all agreed
we're not going to do that again because
it was just it was too massive of a
crowd and we promoted and we did a live
show change my mind is meant to be
something where you set up and random
passers-by
dig conversate with you tis meant to
mimic more so what occurs in real life
but right away we were in Austin fire
bomb them so we're trying to protect our
fans and our team and we were in
violation of what guidelines are you
saying here's
so crazy means in order to create a safe
space for professional online victims
they're literally creating unsafe spaces
in the physical world from acts of
serious violence and brutality coming
from the left but Stephen you disagree
Galvan Gary so rich these are the people
that are teaching teaching cutting
colleges right through the professors
and then the administrators that are in
college is teaching your kids you're
paying money to go to come on all we
need to create a safe space maybe this
is out of brown shirts on the street
people to be offended online right right
so on Instagram Twitter like people's
feelings that really hurt we don't say
okay so the only way that we can create
a safe space online don't get hurt yeah
is by hurting people in real life that's
true follow me follow me online safe
space real life firebomb the violence of
the spear by the way circle penis is a
figment of your imagination okay carry
on if you want an A in my course check
yes to agree with all of these otherwise
are setting about I hate all the things
and this is why we just that we sent
spend computer into act this is why
we've become disruptive [ __ ]
sometimes look we do change my mind you
know we do it because it's meant to be
civil as men to have a dialogue but
every now and that we send in spend it
wasn't very productive the whole point
was to point out the only point was to
to showcase the absurdity of the left
yes to publicly embarrass these people
why because even when we're as civil as
humanly possible even when we play by
every single one are you see what Tommy
Robinson or you see it with with with
sardonic account on Twitter or lady not
heated breaks in rows but you see with a
lot of people certainly when we play by
every single one of the contradictory
sometimes illegal borderline illegal
like party consent state laws as far as
filming arbitrary rules they get changed
to screw us anyway so why does it seem
like we're becoming increasingly hostile
right why does it feel like on sometimes
this show we go too far why are we
sending spend back in for super but
you're gonna see on money's gonna have
your pee yourself laughing why is it
like we're doing this works sometimes
unnecessary and there's no point other
than to irritate the left because you
that's why and here's the other thing we
have an official statement though from
the Trump he's been quiet we have to do
this before we actually we have to get
going I've run over time he's been
pretty
quiet seemed a little conflicted Kim
jong-un has released an official
statement yes regarding the meeting with
Trump and how he feels about it and
let's go after that sorta dawn of a cot
I met for president last night
Donald Trump gave me a fright he said
I'm kind of a dick he's right
I'm tired of faking I'm tired of right
it's wrongly
inkay
[Music]
just cuz I start
oh my citizens
[Music]
should I think it's gonna be a run wrong
time to Donald Trump begins to really
fine I'm not a Terran that he thinks I
am oh no no I'm just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Rafi bear
you
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
that's like a Big Brother program if
they spanked you already glad I'm on the
Weller's what's everyone last weekend we
I don't know it's been been a while he's
been stateside and now he's no longer
stateside so I'm kind of sorry that we
missed him but you can follow him on
YouTube because I don't think you can
follow them much anywhere else anymore
sargon of a CAD mr. Kent how are you sir
I'm very well you can actually follow me
on Facebook still ok click haven't
banned me yet yeah well you know what I
noticed that your no work Instagram is
is way worse than than Facebook and it's
obviously owned by Facebook we had
someone say we had someone from not from
an if my actual we just talked about it
someone who works at UT we just talked
about this earlier on the show demand
that people firebomb us while we were
doing it changed my mind you know highly
controversial segment and tweeted it all
out and then I posted a picture saying
hey watch out for this person because
they want to firebomb us and I
apparently violated policies by posting
their exact suite right so very
difficult to follow yeah but you're
still a smoke so that's good hey you
were in the States for a while what what
what was that like for you was it was it
your first long visit stateside no no
I've been to the States a few times
before um I was really good I went to
the University of Portland Portland
State University where I was invited to
talk with Professor Peter pegasion who's
a philosophy pres in there and he's he's
been harassed endlessly by the sjw's and
yeah we were talking about bias response
teams at the university which are
basically I mean I'm not being
hyperbolic when I say they're kind of
like a progressive version of the police
of vice and virtue okay if you if you're
doing something that falls outside of
progressive orthodoxy you can be
reported them and it doesn't have to be
a crime it you know is in I mean
obviously they've got no legal power
it's just if you're doing something that
can be considered offensive and this I
mean this could this could be down to
obviously using language that is deemed
inappropriate as University not swear
words know like biologically improper
pronouns can be considered yes yes deny
is on the left and the right and
everyone wants to believe it's just the
OP
a team yeah has the salt deniers but um
but yeah and so we we were obviously
interrupted by someone from an C file
pulling the fire alarm but luckily we
managed to pack the hall out I mean I
think the hall had about 800 seats on
nervous seven hundred of them were
filled nice so yeah oh yeah we had to
leave because the fire thing have the
ink so you could spot the s.a.w I would
imagine the SJW were just covered in ink
if they do like someone who tried to rip
off some you know Neiman Marcus in the
90s remember those these two think
they're use it anymore so I'm still
eatin holes it didn't we didn't have
that but some the pharmacy was settled
really quickly and so we went back in
but and in the heart of the the SJW
Menace we got to take a nice big dump
all over they're biased response teams
very nice these are in terms and
philosophy automatic use with the
professor take a nice big dump on their
responsiveness did you notice a very
different sensibility with Americans
than in the UK now being here now in
2018 because I will say it's changed a
lot since I've been in the states and
when I first came from Canada was
culture shock I can only imagine now in
the sense that there's a real divide of
people who support things like the First
Amendment in absolute truth and the
people who pull the fire alarms um well
yeah there's a massive ideological
divide between those two people and it's
not getting smaller right it's because
one side positively refuses dialogue I
mean oh I think one of the reason that
your you'll change my mind
series has been so popular is because
people want to see the conversations
happening that frankly the left have
been shutting down yeah for the last
decade at least and it's got to the
point now where the problems are so bad
and they're so obviously in people's
faces that you can't just pretend that
the person who's bringing up an issue is
a bigot right because there are so many
people with real issues that just you
you can't just assume that I mean was it
Dan Harmon said a third of your country
are Nazis and it's like Dan are you
listening to yourself
yeah do you really think that a third of
America has been taken over by Nazis or
is it your perception has gone so far
radically to the left that you're
basically a communist at this point
third was that well what percentage of
Germans were Nazis
I think as a third is more the Nazi
Party one was something like 37 percent
of the votes right but that doesn't
obviously make 37 percent of the Germans
Nazis the party so more Americans are
Nazis they're Nazis or not there's the
Nazis sleeping giant waiting maybe if he
meant right time campus a third of
people on campus were like this lady who
worked at UT she was one of the firebomb
us for the change my mind it was a her
to dangers changed my mind by the way
here's the crazy thing
the lady who sat down and we was a man
was a transgender man to woman that was
the one conversation that was civil it
was the feminist who claimed to be
intersex which I read up afterward I
think is BS
who screamed and screech it was the UT
Asian Registrar's Office who wanted to
firebomb us the transgender person uh
him/herself Z self wasn't that upset
pretty pretty reasonable so it isn't it
is anyway but have you noticed there's a
distinct um supply and demand problem
when it comes to Nazis there's a massive
demand for Nazis right now they want
nancy's to be everywhere but the market
just isn't filling this so I'm basically
thinking if I opened a Nazi University I
could fill that niche in the mark yes
you could if for nothing else the Hugo
Boss uniforms
you could you could start a storefront
well yeah I mean I I mean I'm not really
much of a nazi myself but I'm sure I
could probably dig up one or two we
could learn you know I mean for Crowley
we can make a lot of money off at sea
you know just so some paths though some
patches on their sell some soap make it
a package so so what was it the most
bizarre thing you can oh we saw some of
the antiphon videos but at a certain
point it becomes white noise I hate to
say it unless you because then you're
committing acts of violence and falling
so many fire alarms what would you say
this was your weirdest encounter in the
States
um actually you you've seen the show
Portlandia haven't you yes I went from
the bookstore that the the oh yeah shows
based around um and it was really I mean
it was like tumblr had come to life
everything in it was everything and it
was like the most cliched SJW feminist
nonsense I mean obviously a black lives
matter and all this you know pace of the
cross walls and I went in there and I
got some buttons and my favorite one
that the button and ironically said
riots not diets
I know what it's an anti fat shaming
thing if you say we should lose weight
we're getting some riots and it's like
that's not gonna last and no you would
have to riots if you just lost a few I
just she knows they genuine they they
not only do they think that it's more
productive to riot and instead of live a
healthy lifestyle
they believe that it is so much more
productive in fact that it deserves real
estate on a button in the take a penny
leave a penny jar I I paid a dollar 50
for this bug because I was like I'm
never gonna find anything like this
anywhere else and you know what the
really unfortunate thing about this is I
was one of the last people to purchase
something from that shop because it's
shut down yeah because the evil
capitalist patriarchy for some reason
won't sustain it well they don't want to
they don't want to buy that many
Birkenstock so I understand it's
oppressive from and you could feel that
market you could feel more good with
that see they're basically messing up
because eventually it's gonna be me
having the the Nazi University the
feminist bookstore communist commune as
well anything that I can make profitable
I think I'm going to go for I am a
capitalist yes it's like playing Harvest
Moon at this point in our PG only you
end up making a lot of money off of
stupid people commerce cafeteria it's
always empty it's the final question if
you've been founded Tommy Robinson
controversy yes I mean there are some
things that I've talked about in this
where I'm like man I really do feel
shame sometimes from Mike for some
actions on behalf of my country this is
one thing that got to imagine every even
some leftist Brits have come out and
said I can't believe this this has gone
really far and I'm praying that the guy
doesn't I know you're an atheist but I'm
just praying and hoping the guy doesn't
get hurt this could end really badly
well yeah I mean okay so the the Tommy
Robinson's situation is interesting and
complicated when some some I three
months ago he was arrested for doing the
same thing which is filming and
broadcasting outside or on court
property when that's prohibited because
it the the worry is that it will
prejudice the jury
and so there's a lot about you doing
this and he was caught doing this he was
suspended sentence of three months I
think it was and obviously told not to
do that within that time and within that
time he went and did the same thing
right and then was arrested and charged
with but potentially prejudicing a jury
and so the suspect the suspended
sentence was just recalled and so this
is why he's gone to jail but on the face
of it it looks like this one incident
isn't really it looks like it's Tommy's
fault and to be fair in this case it is
Tommy's fault but this isn't this isn't
an isolated incident of the police being
frankly prejudiced and heavy-handed with
Tommy I mean there this is this is one
bad example really because there are
dozens of other examples where on film
you will see leftist protesters
attacking Tommy and his friends and the
police will arrest Tommy and not the
attackers and the really the question
becomes here the law isn't worth the
paper it's printed on if it's not
applied equally and I searched high and
low it's very hard to find somebody else
who got this kind of a sentence for for
filming effectively a child rapist you
know I mean we're talking about let's be
clear here yeah listen there's a law I
understand it that's why we have single
party consent laws in the states I think
it's very important but putting someone
in a prison for effectively berating the
worst of the worst among humanity who
get lesser sentences that's the issue
here and then transferring him to a
prison which we're still waiting on some
information it sounds like it sounds
like do you think this final question
and we have to go do you think that
YouTube social media and and governments
are in cahoots because they removed this
video where he talked about this
happening you know it just got removed
this week there's some what it's not so
much they're in cahoots it's more the
governments are especially European
governments which are even even when
they're not left-wing they're quite
left-wing and they're quite progressive
you know I mean like for example my
Prime Minister claims to be a
conservative but then she claims to be a
feminist and it doesn't make sense yeah
so it's not that they're in cahoots it's
really that the government's are chasing
after the social media platforms because
they're tired of people saying things
that the governments don't like because
we don't have free speech everything off
then it's well you said it not me
whenever I say it a lot of you don't
know it you don't know you think America
do any places free yes yes I do yes I do
because yeah right that's why yes you
actually have a constitutional amendment
that guarantees your freedom of speech
we don't have that we do not that's why
I do not go back to Canada Ireland and
Poland maybe at least seem like they're
a little bit more lenient all right best
place to find you is on YouTube I know
you're on Facebook now but it's still
sargon of akkad right you don't have to
change it okay sargon of akkad we'll
have to get you back on sooner and get
you back stateside sooner because I know
people here are loving it well I'm
actually planning a trip to Texas at
some point because I've got a lot of
subscribers there and I have a lot of
requests so I think I think I have to
bow to market demands in that regard and
and do my duty I'll be sure to let the
fire Bombers in Austin Texas no Sargon
thank you very much Dean quenette's
thank you so first time what were your
or your thoughts if you were to buy one
for yourself what would you get the
nine-millimeter ppq yeah that's actually
my mom just started shooting there you
go what were your thoughts only like the
first time ever shooting fire but came
in I was very relaxed I picked up the
Walther yeah and it was very good with
it you're very yeah right off the bat
you were good so are you going to be
buying the fire
[Music]
run away
I had something that within my walk I
don't know what need to tobacco beetle
from all the pipes no no it could be a
blues roofie we have this pain around
the studio disgusting by the way very
glad to have our next guest although
don't get used to looking at you I can't
figure out if you're kim jeong-hoon or
Al Pacino's Paterno in the HBO film it's
it's kind of a find your own truth on
that yeah to choose your own path and
either way it ends up to someone being
sexually accosted against their well
next guest big fan at real Dean Cain and
I do if the plug he just sent it to me
before the program masters of illusion
begins season five here in late June
he's filming another documentary on
Holocaust deniers a whole bunch of
Inferno team came to they mess anything
up there oh no you didn't miss any of
that up at all the only thing you
neglected to add was that on Tuesday
I'll be being sworn in as a reserve
police officer in st. Anthony's Idaho
Wow how did that come about
uh it's actually it's a task force that
Erik Estrada is on and he's a friend of
mine for a long time and Estrada isn't
as an actual police officer he actually
is an actual police officer as I will be
in less than a week did you have to go
through training do you have to go to
deploy yeah all kinds of goodies uh okay
well then that bad congratulations but
it begs seems like a long ways to get
your concealed carry permit now pay
that's not a short path I would pay to
see Dean Cain and Steven Seagal come to
fisticuffs because I know he he he had
that show lawman for a while yeah but
Declan that was tough to watch Dean I
would run around him I'm tired and I
would claim victory after a heart attack
and then you
that's exactly what I want you to I
don't have to go to Russia to see him I
don't want to go to when Dean Cain in
that room
you ever notice this always tries to
allude to the step but you're like well
Hoss I gonna be your ever ever actually
fought well and I can say you'd rather
not find out but have you no know I've
never felt so okay speaking of which you
know we never want to get when we have
celebrities who are often find
themselves opposite some these other
actors in films we never want to get you
guys in trouble or cause drama or there
needn't be any but Robert DeNiro I guess
you're kind of at your wits end with the
guy well I mean to get up on stage of
the Tonys and just say those two words
you know about the current president
fine if you don't agree with him say
something like that but to just say that
and then getting a standing ovation and
doing a so brave huh yeah it's so not
rage that's the whole point I know
that's what you meant but I mean it's
incredible to me I do it's embarrassing
so lemming-like
it's ridiculous so I just don't
understand you know yeah okay so yes the
president has used press language in the
past yeah so not wonderful
I've never supported it I don't support
it now but that's just ridiculous
yeah and two wrongs don't make a right
and you can't blame Trump for his you
know what he has said this is something
very dad like two wrongs don't make a
right bust and my son just turned 18 by
the way he graduated from high school my
wings are no longer clipped I can go
anywhere and do anything and he can come
with me did you give it did you give him
the boot out of the house right away say
get a job total you know you got three
or four days gave him some bleep time
okay actually notice on his bedroom
doors and I'm keeping the gaming chair
do you find that they've been there go
ahead good you Odie's do you find that
the robert do your stuff up for me like
i was able to put it on mine for a while
now it's just I can't even go back and
watch the movies I liked with him it
makes it hard yeah I see that
I don't I can make that distinction just
because it's easy extended too many
actors as it is that would really pretty
much ruin every movie I ever watched
true so I can make that distinction I
think he's a fine actor I obviously
think he's done a great career he does
very work it's just that sort of stuff
it it just
that that was beyond the pale for me and
I'm really embarrassed for the people
who stood up and applauded that because
they're such hypocrites were to happen
you know I didn't love President Obama
and his policies but I wouldn't ever
stood up and done that I probably would
have I'm not gonna lie but I wouldn't
have expected it I wouldn't have
expected a standing ovation from
Hollywood and I wouldn't and I wouldn't
have here's also something else I would
say doing that an award ceremony would
be much more brave than doing it toward
Trump that's why I remember Johnny
Ramone when he said I love the United
States I love george w bush and you
heard ooh gasps because that was brave
yeah you know if you just compare it
it's not the same thing either because
if you just compared unemployment alone
across the board you would have had a
reasonable excuse to chance in chance
and you know denounced Obama because of
his policies that later those numbers
but Trump is doing really well so when
you boo Trump right now it just kind of
second you hate America well that's a
good point yes that's what Oprah wisdom
does she was talking she's like now I
know it's really hard for going out
there right now do you do they genuine
are they so enclosed that they don't
understand that most Americans including
people by the way in the bottom
percentile as far as earnings are
keeping more of their check that that
costs are going taxes are going down
that employment is going up to people
who are they not aware of this do they
think everyone's going yeah the economy
sucks right now
they are not aware of it they think it
everyone is saying yeah the economy
sucks right now it's unbelievable
because you know if you watch five
different news channels that's what
you're going to hear you're gonna hear
all the terrible thing President Trump
and Kim jong-il thought that sat down
Kim Jong wouldn't turn I can't tell cuz
you guys yeah there's the dead one and
the fat one
we had it all the time yeah I'm Asian I
can say it you know they're really
stretching the limits of that yellow
pass right there that's my given name
which I was accused of changing as I
became a Hollywood guy even though I got
adopted and that was the name I was
given yeah I don't know sorry about that
thank you for that yes okay okay so yeah
so you really do so you think it's just
they have no idea I think they have I
think they have no idea I really
they have no concept because they sits
down they have its historic summit and
this wonderful stuff happens and they
hear how it's terrible to be sitting
down and and legitimizing a dictator
what and just two weeks ago they're
complaining about we're pulling out of
the Iranian deal I'm like hold us I can
pick a lane
we're used to the to the diamond line
the HOV Lane I called the carpool lane
and also I lanes put on my motorcycle
down the 405 Lowe up Dominic put that
truck one that Trump was riding you came
my people who a lot of people have seen
this although I will say there's been a
definitive increase in plays on your
prints and highlight since we've talked
about it it really is people don't
realize people who don't know yes so
much they're actually flogging as hate
speech it's like it hates me just really
weird and it's a mistake as somebody who
was a real athlete a high-level athlete
what do you think like we just kind of
talked about Steven Seagal but same
thing was kind of Robert DeNiro you've
heard him do this what really bothers me
more so it's not if they say hello F
Trump okay I understand it sucks but
when they play this tough-guy thing
because they did four weeks of training
to do fighting for the stage you know
boxing for the camera which is very
different from boxing and real life as
someone who was a real athlete people go
watch American Gladiator back in the I
think it was the early 90s
Dean Cain one smoked it was you and
actually another good athlete the guy
from Scrubs I forgot the name of the
actor's name Donald McKinley yeah he was
but it wasn't even close at the final
team can you smoke them what do you
think when you see these guys who play
who play tough guy who you know they're
a part of the high school drama club
yeah it's it's that doesn't bother me I
mean they play tough guys that's it but
it's all rhetoric it's all baloney you
know I listen when Chris Kyle says
something I listen to that yeah you know
I when somebody who was a former Ranger
if it's sean Parnell that says it I
listen you know okay this is a guy who's
been right through it sure but you never
see them use that sort of language or
that sort of a tone yeah because they to
what it is so you know De Niro go oh
yeah it's tough I mean I don't know what
that was plus you're 77 years old we
guys got a fight I mean I don't what is
that I just don't get it you're it
didn't he say you wanted to punch Donald
Trump or was that
so for them so they actually wanted to
fight him like that was I mean I've been
DeNiro and yours think we don't just
play trout we have a playground in
elementary school I mean that's what it
is what they don't think about it
because I've said this Donald Trump was
a guy when he was running and for
example he said Ted Cruz's dad
assassinator GfK I said the prom with
President Donald Trump at this point
Donald Trump he wasn't president I said
he's never gotten his ass kicked and
it's not because there's nothing wrong
with being raised wealthy or silver
spoon but there is something to be said
for being a guy who's gotten your ass
kicked or called on your BS at some
point and I don't think President Trump
has that's why he doesn't understand in
the real world you call someone's wife
ugly and say his dad assassinated JFK
you're probably gonna get your ass
kicked right see that's a point but just
saying oh oh no punch Donald Trump it's
it's it's at the point of being
nonsensical but the beauty of this is I
really this is happening at the same
time we've talked about this everyone's
sort of the moans that there will never
be the big numbers of Johnny Carson
again or the numbers of the big three
but we're sitting Cobra Kai is Cobra Kai
is getting thirty five forty million
plays Bruce yeah we had Ralph Macchio on
the show you've gone back to the big
three with Netflix Hulu Amazon and maybe
HBO all of these a lot of these
additional superfluous cable channels
are going away and it's happening at a
time where conservatives were the
American public have more access to
information I really do think that
people like DeNiro are losing their
stranglehold and they're like a baby
being put to sleep right now I sure hope
so anyone a bottle you know being came
not giving back not giving me Betty
you're gonna give me Betty I think I
would probably just look at his pathetic
I mean like what the hell but let me say
this all right because you said that was
made me very excited cuz I finished I
have to work today and I'm going back
whatever then my son and I are gonna
watch the first Karate Kid he's never
seen the first one he's only seeing
Jaden Smith one oh gosh I did that's
your fault as a parents you've dropped
it is I take that one I think I own that
yeah that's completely my fault but
we're gonna watch the original one and
then we're going to sit down and just
rip through
I'm so excited for that it's a good yet
I've seen it dying to see it very good
it's really worth watching very good
show and it really it writes for what it
is the show you know I mean it doesn't
try to be more than it is but there is
there's a the characters are very
empathetic I've already talked about it
on this show but I would say it's one of
the best shows to come out in a while
unfortunately for you too I think the
numbers are showing that a bunch of
people open to YouTube red account wash
Cobra Kai and then closed it back up
because you know you can binge watch
right now but I do recommend it and then
you can teach her something less when he
watches the original critic and see see
see that's very different from the Jaden
Smith version which is the only parallel
universe where the black kid gets
bullied by a bunch of smaller Asian kids
that's that happen oh my gosh i watch
that Jaden Smith thing like Oh
Braca kid first instinct is to Bui even
though he is a foot taller I have a four
anyway you know I have friends actually
well he's been I don't think if he's
been on the show but I spell well then
Bob Sapp Japanese people are terrified
of black people do you realize this
terrified of Bob Sapp yeah and I know
that the one was Chinese and I'm mixing
Asians right now but you don't care
because every yellow pass all right that
is at real Dean Cain and its masters of
illusion season five and where can
people where can people find that that
have a seat its local suppress the CW
whatever it is for whatever you are and
whichever part of this lovely great herb
flowers I don't know where it is in safe
Dallas Texas I don't know there's no
idea maybe we're in Austin it could be
channel three could be channel seven but
you're gonna see that wonderful poem
down there I think we have to get going
we have Derek smalls Derek smalls are
from spinal tap on after this I know I
keep you on but you got a go deep
[Music]
now available at lotto would Crowder
shop calm are genuine authentic Ranger
panties the softest lightest Ranger
panties available with a built in silk
soft support liner these Lotter with
Grutter Ranger panties feel like tea
bagging an angel it's in doing things
like yard work or tending the garden
they keep me cool entraining like you
ain't pull up our dead Hanks these
Ranger panties are so convenient
supportive and comfortable they can be
used for almost anything like watching
TV doing the laundry laying the front
the fireplace like Fred Reynolds hid
deep or for covering up at those
important meetings for supporting
America Canada buy yours today at Lauder
with routers shop comm louder with
Crowder Ranger pants because the freedom
of the Republic is at stake
[Music]
they're open all right one of my
episodes probably guessed I'm most
excited about ever having on our program
very very few accomplishments on this
show that I'm proud of genuinely
speaking are there and there are two
musical artists who have talked about
when I get in this show mm-hmm Alice
Cooper was wandering on because of his
fascinating biography and our next guest
you know him of course from the band
spinal tap then known as tap and you
know him of course you can follow him on
twitter at smalls life his newest album
is actually a solo album right now
smalls change meditations upon aging you
know who he is at this point but I have
mr. Derek smalls thank you sir for being
here Thank You Steven it's a pleasure I
am so glad to have you I obviously know
your your work with with the band quite
a bit and and now you're going solo
later in your career well what was the
inspiration for doing this when did you
just say you know what did you wake up
one day and say this is this is for me
I'll pick up every day if you when did I
make this decision yes it was well the
band you know has a history break if we
don't break up I shouldn't say breaking
up because we don't do that don't you
know yell and curse each other and throw
things cuz you never had that many
things to throw but we would you would
dissolve right you know you know that do
you know that the the old super country
Pangaea you know that no I don't it was
like the big it was the big
supercontinent that they realized was
before all the continents split off oh
yes one continent yes called Pangaea and
then and you know this like 300 million
years ago and then you turn around three
million years later and there's Africa
and this South America and this
Australia right and that's where it was
like I turned around and there was no
more Pangaea right well it's almost like
the you know the West Indies trading
company employed I think about a fifth
of population earth and then you know
even they had to change and evolve and
people went their own separate ways and
I I'd say that the band would be
certainly comparable
in scope to that so you don't break up
you more dissolve so doesn't mean it's
on amicable terms are you still good
friends with not on the band are you
saying there's no more West India
Trading Company unfortunately yeah it's
been it's been a while well miss they
might be in a new name like so that's
why they don't deliver any more
prominently from not next year
yeah well Nigel I are on good terms he's
got his hands full he's I should say
it's a hobby buddies for him it was for
tada
he's breeding miniature livestock down
in the farmer Berkshire okay and you
know I know I know Nubian goats but what
else is there well he started with
horses because horses as you may recall
again at the time of Pangea door later
were smaller to begin with we've bred
them up he's trying to breed them back
down to where they came from so if it
reforms don't know where they are so he
but he's an extreme personality he's a
guitar player they say these are the
icarus is rock and roll you know they'd
flock to the Sun and get the wings
burned and then you know I've got to
come and get sunscreen on their wings
yeah so he's pushed it too far the
horses and now too small to have you
can't find trouble small enough to ride
them so he's got his hands and he does
do goats now as you meant yeah but those
again
now the too small to milk so yeah you
know he keeps hitting the wall what
David I I have no idea I get letters
from him because I don't use the
Internet I really shouldn't be doing
this today but I appreciate you taking
the time yeah I would say about the
goats he if he staggers you know that's
a big thing he may not have a lot of
experience farming if he staggers the
goats with the milking he might he might
be a little bit more successful so if
they drink some alcohol you they stagger
that can happen yeah of this now when
you when you stagger them time time wise
you know you milk one and you allow the
other sort of reach out to me yeah yeah
yeah I see Pepsi
ask me I will tell him yeah no I I
wouldn't be I wouldn't feed the goats
alcohol but you never know you could you
could create a new thing let me ask you
this Oh since like you said you don't
use the internet a whole lot
what's it like you know going on the
road now at your respectfully your your
your at your age your you're older
you're much older I'm older yeah but
what does the internet have I mean the
internet didn't make me old no but but
being on the road now is that is that
hard a lot harder you know what your age
than when you were you know younger I'd
imagine no it's still fun I mean one of
the cycle is called rock and roll
transplant and it's about how rock and
roll will keep you young and there's
another tune on the record these record
these songs all deal with the questions
you're asking Stephen vini Utley enough
and so one of these Corey don't get old
and it's about the rock-and-roll
lifestyle and it's about basically if
you're at the top of if you're at
anything it's you know private jets and
the best champagne and the best women
with the best men if that's what you're
into no judgement and and that's like
then you're you're a few no but if
you're a few rungs down like me then
it's you know can look a little seating
a little dodgy and you think wow you get
up there and it doubled that's the
support the song no II don't get cuz you
didn't think what could I be doing
otherwise I'd be sitting in a bedsit you
know waiting for the telly did burnout
well I'm curious because you say that
you know there seems to be this duality
to the album I know I know the songs
that you've you've talked about but then
you also have she puts the [ __ ] in the
obituary is one of your songs
no bitchery yes yes and then and hell's
toupee where Satan is actually concerned
about his aging appearance so you kind
of talk about sort of staying young but
there's also this I notice an underlying
theme that it almost seems as though
you're you you have some fear of coming
to terms maybe with age
well yeah in has its own gang doesn't it
yeah for every year there's a yang I
think is the way the Chinese put it so
yeah this song on the record like a memo
to Willy which Donald Fagen is a guest
vocalist on the smokey puppy horns
around it they've got great guests on
the record I know David Crosby Keith
Richards right right I know
Peter Frampton I think am I missing an
oh crap turns out Frampton Satriani
Steve Lukather Thompson Paul Shaffer
Rick Wakeman Rick Wakeman to me but I
was sick about memo - really it's a song
about people men who think that there's
a little problem downstairs I've come to
your country and I see these adverts you
know which have these blokes into the
30s maybe early forties nice-looking
geezers you know we're at the lake in
the canoe with a nice-looking piece of
carpet or you know hiking or bicycling
nice policy active I understand the
theme very active it looks like the gone
and all of a sudden a voice comes on
when the time comes will you be ready
I'm thinking is this a some kind of
epidemic that I've missed so the point
of the song is need to take a pill you
know just chemical that's turn talking
to get it up get it up yeah so it's so
it's not it's not a negative it's not a
positive it just is it's just sort of an
isolated motivational speech for Willie
before they will yet for the Williams
everybody everybody needs a pep talk
yeah that's it again you talked a lot
about meditation I know in a lot of
interviews do you is this something you
do you do specific meditations for that
that Anatomy for for Willie it sounds
like maybe you do no no no you yeah
meditation would slacken you up a bit I
think yeah I think yeah I haven't tested
it myself but I believe that to be the
case that's why the monks doing yes
it's very least I mean the monks do it
and they they do they do the Mongolian
throat singing that's something that
also I've seen people do that you'd be
amazed at the amount of as a musician
the amount of wind that can be moved
final question let me ask you this how
you seem obviously you're sharp you're
with it you're doing the solo career now
what keeps you going what keeps you so
fresh compared it this seems like
there's a real steep drop off with
rockers either you have people like
yourself or Alice Cooper if people that
make Jagger and then you have people
kind of like you know go the route of
Ozzy Osbourne how do you do it what's
the secret
well I do have a physical determine that
I maintain which is I like to run the
resistance run against water mm-hmm and
you know it's you're supposed to do in a
pool it's great for your lungs it's
great for your heart it's great for your
legs I don't have a pool
I do the tub but it so you get some of
the same of effect right but more the
point Stephen base players are not like
guitar players you know we're not though
success you've fly to the Sun and get
your wings burn to have people we're
with it with the glue of the band
we own the fountain today the building
you know we're the lukewarm water as I
say so
well I think that gives us a little bit
of staying power that the high fliers
may not have yeah I just a guest know I
may may be right the baseline keeps the
whole the whole tune together so it
makes sense that you keep the whole band
together you're the glue that that holds
it together um I would imagine though
listen I mean I would yeah go ahead I'm
sorry I'm just gonna say you know
drummers come and go the bass players
always there that's a history with you I
didn't want to touch I didn't know if it
was a sore spot you're you're in your
history of touring your drummers with
your bands they have not fared very well
is what when you're going solo now how
do you do with the backup instruments
who who to use as a drummer and has it
been going a little less rocky well it
goes rocky in the senses we rock but I
know what you mean it here's the thing
I'm not the Satanist per se but I do
understand a few things about the old
two people one and he's ever enough with
the number three okay well spinal tap
was David nog and me and we were a
threesome that we had people with us you
know a drummer so Satan was hung up with
that and he thought no no no turning the
three into four that can have that yeah
freaked out a bit the deal Lucifer now
I'm a one on a solo artist okay every
drummer displayed on this record Chad
Smith Taylor Hawkins Todd super moment
and
be Stern ed chalpin amazing rock
drummers have wronged him up after the
session sir how you doing mate never
been
I never been I'm glad to hear I'm glad
to hear that but doesn't necessarily um
I don't know if that proves your theory
because as long as you have a guitarist
in a drummer you still have at least
three members in the band so someone's
got to be number three but the band that
they're just did my my side man okay so
they're not okay right right isn't it
doesn't hit Satan in the same way in the
same part of he's really yeah I don't
I'm not exactly sure in the biology of
the underworld you say you're not a
Satanist per se we what does that mean
laveyan satanism you know I don't engage
rituals and things like that I just you
know I realize that this is an important
character the scheme of the earth and
it's good to pay attention to and keep
it good and in good terms you know it's
like girl it's like trumpets in North
Korea you know what is amor yeah no
you're you're absolutely right that
makes a lot of sense and it seems as
though you know sometimes you just got
out crazy the other crazy guy and then
everyone's crazy the album we do have to
get going thank you so much is smalls
change meditations upon aging and people
can find that where mr. Small's where's
the best place for him everywhere
records are either stay oh no rent but
it's extremely available right now but
Apple music iTunes Spotify the estranged
chap at the corner who still sells
physical records yeah well I wouldn't
want to plug him he's probably probably
bugging you're not you're not making
much profit off of that but I I
appreciate the spirit that is Derek
smalls thank you so much and we have to
wrap this show up thank you very much
mr. Small's you be well and we'll look
forward to seeing how this
[Music]
yesterday once you go to Johnson was it
is that my panel breaking down the
binary yeah that was it Jeff goes
yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm moving a heavy-ass rowboat you ever
seen a really fat guy float on his back
yeah it's one of the funniest thing I'll
been to pools
looks like mr. Ratburn and Arthur when
it was like the shark thing only it's a
gut ah thank you so much to start gonna
have a cod Dean Cain Derek smalls
fantastic show we have an unbelievable
lineup next we have one thing I'm real
excited about Brian Shaw world Strongest
Man is going to be on I'm not sure if we
have Laci green on for a long form and
that we're gonna have obviously the big
video Monday
Sven computer innovated in listen just
in case you're wondering is this gonna
be the video like debunking democratic
socialism that I send along no this is
the kind of this is not this place for
that hopefully you just really get a
huge laugh out of it because you realize
that they do operate behind closed doors
they claim they want one thing and then
we go behind closed doors and they're
trying to teach you how to get taxpayer
funded puberty blockers for
six-year-olds yeah well more of a safe
space can you get when you when it's one
against how many and they're in a single
room and they're on their terms hurts
him up yeah yeah I don't suppose don't
good you know another boards are
expensive I think continuing to with
just this line we have Anthony communion
I know it'll actually I don't know what
I'm really excited about that um I
actually at one point didn't know like
if we were on the outs because he hadn't
been on in awhile and because you know
you know some people who were at his
network or now at CRT trick no so he's
he's a great guy a lot of people were
asking me that and I never answered so
just so you know I think um he's gonna
be on I'm real excited he's like he's an
encyclopedia of comedy yeah the
Cyclopaedia Britannic of comedy you know
he never did stand-up very very funny
very sharp guy demons you know this is
we're just I'm a Tommy Robinson and
we'll follow me on Twitter and not gay
Jared on Twitter and we'll do everything
because we can't always post videos
about Tommy Robinson but on Facebook on
Twitter on Instagram we're gonna try and
keep you guys updated I really am just
you know I keep keeping I know thoughts
and prayers sound like they don't mean
much anymore but I really do feel bad
for the guy and you know what you do
realize you get to this point now you
you know the left cannot complain about
civility
when they push you this far what's like
one second when someone wanted to
firebomb me and I post it saying hey hey
if
see these people trying to firebomb a
stop and you ban your BAE in my post
well can we just find some common ground
no can we just have some civility no you
have a child rapist and then he have
Tommy Robinson calling out the child
rapist maybe skirted the law I
understand maybe some gray area there I
understand maybe Brooke but but he gets
a harsher sentence then he say listen
can you see our point of view no no we
can't we are mr. and mrs. civility or
were the ones who started to change my
mind segments we had Christopher Titus
on when he came on where he came on and
told me you don't care about that you we
had him back but you cannot push people
this far and then expect to and then
convinced about the divide [ __ ] about
the ideological divide in this country
you know that's why I'm ok with it we
have to fight back so hard at this point
put it this way if Tom Lee Robinson gets
killed in prison I will personally be
advocating for a revolution and I don't
mean just some words if that man gets
killed in prison if that happens that's
about as bad as it gets right that
that's the sound the alarm and I'm not
being conspiratorial here we've reached
this point we're in it just today it
cascaded was what how did we violate we
don't even know how we're violating
policies no and it's almost like not
explaining yeah hold on a second they
hosted a town hall yes was open yes
invitation yes single party consent
state yes the man was handing out his
car dr. Rex but actual name yes we
videotaped it where they were talking
about putting kids on puberty blockers
yes why is it removed he didn't like it
and here's here's a here's something
important for audience is understand
that we're not just complaining because
it always hurt our channel or hurt our
but we are what we're going up against
is the entire mechanism for which you
receive information yeah it's being it's
being curated by people behind closed
doors to see what exactly what they want
you to see day in and day on it goes
well beyond our channel and they try to
feed you that with along with that
information hey let's have a dialogue
you don't want a dialogue and this is
one thing they often say to they oh you
were the situation's a little bit more
nuanced than that conservatives are so
reductive that's why we're divided no
it's not more nuanced sometimes there is
times there there is no more nuance they
said fire bomb loud orth Crowder changed
my mind we said hey guys be aware they
might try to fire bomb yet where's the
nuance in that and you banned our post
one person is a child rapist one person
reports of someone being a child rapist
where's the nuance in that one person
obeys the law to create content and
employs people one person flagrantly
disregards it where's the nuance in that
and you can't just keep asking for
nuance while you push people further and
further you push them to a cliff they're
gonna do some crazy desperate desperate
things and that's what you're about to
see you don't think Tommy Robinson right
now you don't think he's desperate
listen we we're having a meeting with
with half-asian Lerner bill Richmond on
Friday because there are some things
behind the scenes that when I think
about and I try to focus on the positive
and we talk about this a lot and I know
usually this final segment is somewhat
inspirational but you sure when I think
about it if I spend more than 45 seconds
I get really pissed off because we've
been playing by the rules and all of the
people that you see in this studio not
to mention everyone in the edit Suites
and people who write at laterals credit
calm people at Cortney and Brautigan and
Cory they depend on us knowing the rules
to make a living what are the rules okay
here's the rule sheet all right we're
following the rules we're gonna ban you
anyway but it's more nuanced can you
tell me the nuance nope but can you just
be civil about it
piss off I'm not gonna be civil about it
of course I'm not going to be civil
about it this term all the time you know
we could do with being a little bit more
reductive I was talking with someone
about this the other day I think I might
actually a debate that hasn't been
uploaded yet that might be uploaded to
channel not entirely sure they reductive
reductive what's wrong with being
reductive you've heard me say this but I
just watch the darkest hour again
recently gary oldman big conservative in
hollywood for those who don't know
Google search Gary Oldman Nancy Pelosi
you will not be disappointed by the
quote but Winston Churchill was
absolutely reductive we will never ever
ever ever ever surrender doesn't get
much more productive than that but
what's wrong with it what's wrong with
it
what's wrong was never ever ever
surrendering to Hitler that you'll fight
with everything you have
it is absolutist it is black and white
it is reductive it is your job to prove
to me why it's wrong just saying
it's reductive doesn't mean anything
there was a but can't we have an honest
conversation just when people just say
something you say something so
emphatically they want you to skim over
it that's reductive well let me go get
scared oh no see okay
how so what's wrong with that what's
wrong with my statement when people and
people say things like only biology's of
social content we all know that oh why
you just made a reductive statement and
trying to claim that I was reductive see
how that works why is it wrong and this
is also why I have a problem with the
right when people say that Tommy
Robinson was sent to a 70% Muslim
population prison this was reported why
you know this widely by several
different sources where we had an
article almost printed up on the website
and we still hold on hold on register
based our researcher and spend spend
computer we said let's do some let's
make sure because I'm seeing these
saintly sources but they're actually
just constantly being linked back to the
same sources and it turned out it wasn't
true thank God we didn't publish it the
truth should be enough the truth this is
the why I have such a problem to grind
with a conspiratorial right who say by
any means necessary they just want to
lie no no that doesn't help at all
either because then you give them some
ammo the truth it's not the truth will
set you free like some stupid some
stupid Trump the people are the truth
let's say that's not what I'm saying but
the truth in this case is enough and
then won't you state the truth and they
tell you it's productive will guess what
the burden is on them to prove to you
why it's wrong sometimes the truth by
its very nature is reductive that's why
it's the truth
certainly absolute truth absolute truth
is the definition of reductive let me
give you some other truths true true
truths that are true absolute truths
that are reductive ok I'm getting tired
my brain is getting reductive fire bomb
them
that's pretty absolute please don't
firebomb me that's pretty absolute I
rape the kid that's pretty absolute
don't rape that kid that's pretty
absolute this is YouTube's policy that's
pretty absolute we're following
YouTube's policy that's pretty absolute
do we changed our policy we're gonna
unemploy all of your staff that seems
pretty absolute so when people try to
tell you there's no absolute truth
they're usually doing so in telling you
through some form of absolute truth
which
is reductive we're at the point right
now where you cannot allow them to push
you off a cliff so prepare be the pig
who builds his house out of brick if you
need a half asian or a or you need a
lawyer with a lot of consonants in his
last name get ready because it's coming
do not allow them to push you off that
cliff because sometimes you can bring so
they're gonna push you off the cliff
like tell me Roberts and guess what they
do they push you off the cliff stop get
your heels get get get your
mexican-style cowboy heels ready if you
need to think of it as an acne cartoon
before the end of that cliff because
once you're off you are gone and then
start pushing back as hard as you
possibly can because the scary part is
now they're not even trying to hide it
they just stick that's reduct if they
just make a statement and assume you're
gonna skim over don't skim over right
now is the time to dig your heels and
look at what they're do it is terrifying
I wish I could be inspiring I wish I
could say that I wake up in a cold sweat
when I see stuff like this it's that bad
out there you've got to do something
that's why I say have tapes of keep
quiet to keep your head down keep
yourself safe know there is there is not
going to be a tomorrow
as far as freedom of speech there will
not be a tomorrow as far as you being
able to fight back you are going to go
off the cliff if you don't fight right
now hopefully you had fun though it's
gonna be really funny funny show on
Monday where Sven goes into LGBTQA a
festival they almost kick his ass see
then
[Music]